the ship sinks Titanic you haven't heard
this movie you are probably not alive
James Cameron directed Titanic and it
was the biggest grossing movie of all
time made more money than any stinking
movie ever made as crap ton of money he
could reach in his sofa and pull out a
million dollar bill but nevertheless
Titanic came out in 1997 and it struck a
chord with a lot of people particularly
young females but the interesting thing
about the movies a camera did a really
good job of making it not just for
females there was a lot of things that
males could really enjoying the movie
particularly Kate Winslet's book but as
you guys know it's the story of what
happened to the Titanic and a
fictionalized betrayal of what happened
on it you know I'll just say this I
really like Titanic I think it's a very
good movie I never think that a movie
deserves 700 million dollars or whatever
it made but I still think it's a good
movie helped launch Leonardo DiCaprio
even farther than he already was Kate
Winslet's obviously a great actress
Billy Zane is in it you can't go wrong
Billy Zane that lets tell you let me
tell you a motto in life that you can
live by you cannot go wrong with Billy
Zane it's impossible listen to your
friend Billy Zane he's a cool dude and
it's being re-released in 3d which means
is being post converted obviously we've
seen some poor conversions we've seen
some okay conversions but let me tell
you that you have never seen a film post
converted into 3d this well this is by
far the best post converted 3d I have
ever seen this movie looks like it was
shot in 3d I was actually more affected
by the 3d in this movie then it was an
avatar the first few shots this movie I
was like how do you do that how this
movie came out in 1997 the post
converted 3d in this movie looks better
than some of the films that were shot in
3d for today I mean it makes those films
cry in the corner
it makes them ashamed to be called 3d
let me just tell you something if anyone
tells you that the 3d in this movie is
not good they're wrong for once in a
lifetime their opinion is wrong Leonardo
DiCaprio's are my favorite actors and
this movie really helped him launch his
career even farther than it was I mean
he was already Oscar nominated for
Gilbert great he was in critters three
of course which is obviously a classic
Cate Wednesday I've never seen her give
a bad performance she's terrific and man
she Prix in this movie this is the kind
that's a woman that's a woman right
there that is a woman let me tell you
right there that's a woman not some
skinny little shrimpy little thing that
you feel like you could be just break if
you sat on her lap sorry she's hot in
that movie man the grand scale of this
movie the musical score by James Horner
Celine Dion's music everything about
this movie just works so much but
honestly probably the best compliment
that I can give for this movie is the
fact that that location worked so well
it seemed so realistic that they were on
that ship in the middle of the ocean I
bought it 100% I mean not one of it
seemed like a set or anything it just
looked so good and that's production
value Titanic could poop out some
production value and sell a lot that
doesn't make sense why do I make these
jokes I don't know the first half of the
movie is this really kind of enchanting
romance and you're supposed to get into
it feel for it and yeah times a little
sappy with the music and the I can I'm
flying I'm flying jack I'm flying I
apologize but you kind of get swept away
into the whole look of the thing in the
field of picture then the last half of
the movie turns into like a disaster
movie of course you know the ship sinks
all this stuff is happening bodies are
flying knocking off propellers and like
tumbling into the water and stuff it's
like dang they gotta live with a lot in
this pg-13 I mean we know what's going
to happen in this movie but there's so
much tension for some reason because
you're really invested in the characters
I love how James Cameron consistently
puts very strong women in his movies
Ripley an alien Sarah Connor Terminator
2 natira from Avatar and now Kate
Winslet's character and Titanic in the
last half of the movie wading through
water with an axe and stuff overall I
really like Titanic I think it's a good
movie the only really problems I have
with it is that it does feel too long
it's like three hours and 15 minutes I
feel like they maybe could have shaved a
good 20 minutes off the movie but it's
hard enough to get swept away by this
movie the feel of it the scope
everything about this film is just big
larger than life and it works very well
for me I'm going to give Titanic an A -
so I'd like to know what's your favorite
James Cameron movie pretty sure mine's
Terminator - pretty sure yeah hasta
LaVista
baby if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes